[موسيقى]
دوله الامارات دائما في تطور ودائما مع
استراتيجيه جعل دوله الامارات من الامارات
السبع مكان لجذب السواح مكان لدعم السياحه
بشكل عام ذاته للسفريات اكبر مروج للسفر
خدمات السفر في دوله الامارات منذ 60 عام
وشهدنا تطورات في دوله الامارات وتطور
السياحه
[موسيقى]
لاحظنا الاهتمام الكبير والمتزايد من سكان
دوله الامارات بخصوص السياحه المحليه
واستكشاف المناطق الدوله سواء في مدينه
راس الخيمه ومدينه الفجيره ومدينه دبي
نلاحظ بشكل كبير نمو المنتجعات والفنادق
والاسامي العالميه والخدمات العالميه التي
تقدم لتامين جوده السفر وجوده الخدمات
المتقدمه من هذه
القطاعات
فنلاحظ على مدى السنين عدد الغرف في
الفنادق تزيد واسامي الفنادق العالميه
التي تقرر الافتتاح في دوله الامارات تكبر
بشكل كبير ودوله المراد دائما صبابه في
التطور والكواكب مع رغبات المستهلك سواء
كانت في عروض مخصصه للعوائل او عروض مخصصه
لفئات معينه من المجتمع ونقدر نشوف مثلا
في اجازه عيد الفطر اقبال كبير من السكان
في دوله الامارات على السياحه الداخليه عو
السياحه الخارجيه او السفر الدولي
ونلاحظ بشكل كبير دول تقوم بزياره دوله
الامارات التي كانت في السنوات الماضيه
نزلت عن الزياره مثل من الصين او من اماكن
ثانيه طبعا حصه كبيره تعود لاوروبا
والاوروبيين ولكن عدد كبير جدا من السياحه
الداخليه ومن السياحه حول دوله الامارات
من دول الخليج ومجلس التعاون
[موسيقى]